كوريا الجنوبيه التي اعلنت انها بصدد
اجراء مناورات النوويه افتراضيه تحاكي
الميدان مع الولايات المتحده بهدف تعزيز
الردع اذا كوريا الشماليه
قال ان هذه المناورات ستنظم في فبراير
شباط المقبل للتعامل مع السيناريو هجمات
النوويه المحتمله من قبل كوريا الشماليه
وكان رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه
مع الولايات المتحده لمواجهه التهديدات
الصاروخيه والنوويه لكوريا الشماليه
وقلينا صول تجري مناقشات مع الجانب
الامريكي في هذا السياق
النقاش بشان التخطيط المشترك الذي يشمل
الاصول النوويه الامريكيه يتضمن تبادلا
للمعلومات بشان استخدام هذه الاصول
والتخطيط والتنفيذ المشتركين ومحاكاتها
على الطاوله وكذلك حاسوبيا المناقشه جاريه
واعتقد انه من الصواب للكوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده ان تتعاونا لان كلينا
يتعرض للتهديد النووي من جانب كوريا
الشماليه
من سوريا
محمد البقالي كثير يجري الان في هذه
المنطقه لكن هنالك قلق بالهجوم نووي اشكري
شمالي
على الاقل هناك قلق زين من تجربه نوويه
اخرى هذا العام الجميع هنا يتوقع بان
بيونغ يونغ ستجري تجربه جديده ثم
بشكل واضح تريد ان تكسب وان تحصل على اكبر
ترسانه نوويه في العالم واعتبرت ان السلاح
النووي هو يمثل جزءا اساسيا من عقيدتها ان
العسكريه هذا من الاضافه الى انها تضع
كوريا الجنوبيه جارتها على راسي اعدائها
المركزيين وفقا لتصنيف الجديد الذي صدر مع
بدايه العام اذا بشكل عام يمكن ان نتحدث
عن توتر واضحه وعن تصعيد من جهه على مستوى
التجارب الصاروخيه التي شاهدناها وعلى
مستوى ما يوصف هنا باستفزازات من خلال
اطلاقا على الاقل اربع صواريخ اربعه
صواريخ باليسيا قصيره وطويله المدى ثم
بالاضافه الى اطلاق طائرات مسيره اخترقت
المجال الجوي الكوري الجنوبي وهذه
الطائرات لم يتمكن الجيش من التصدي لها
وما اثر موجهه قلق من هنا داخل كوريا
الجنوبيه من مدى قدره استعداد الجيش على
التصدي لاي هجوم محتمل وهذا الامر استغله
الرئيس المحافظ الجديد الذي انتخبها عام
2022 ليصب جاما غضبي وليلقي باللوم على
الرئيس السابق الذي كان بشكل عام يوصف
بانه يرغب في التهدئه وخلال فترته
الرئاسيه خفف من المناورات العسكريه
المشتركه مع الولايات المتحده وكان ينظر
اليه الى انه يريد ان يبحث عن حل اكثر
سلميه الرئيس الجديد الكوري الجنوبي الذين
ثقب مؤخرا قام في او اقامه حملته
الانتخابيه على اساس مزيد من التحالف
الوثيق مع الولايات المتحده واليابان ثم
مزيد من التصعيد ومع كوريا الشماليه طبعا
كوريا الشماليه لا ينقصها ذلك فهي اصلا
تذهب في اتجاه التصعيد وبالتالي عندما رات
ان الرد من كوريا من كوريا الجنوبيه فيه
نوع من التصعيد زادت اييي تصعيدا الان
الجديد ما بين الولايات المتحده وبين
كوريا الجنوبيه هذه المناورات هي شيء
اعتيادي منذ عام 2011 لكن هذه المره ااا
الاستعداد ومحاكاه سيناريو هجوم نووي هو
الذي يطرح نفسه ويجعله هذه المناورات ذات
خصوصيه بالغه ليس ذلك فقط وانما هناك ايضا
دعم او استعداد وثيق لتوتر الوضع الذي
يدفع الى الاعتقاد بان احتمالات توتر
الوضع قائمه واحتمالات التصعيد قائمه هو
ما حدث من جهه في اوكرانيا لانه الجميع لم
يكن يتوقع ان تصل الامور الى ما وصلت اليه
وبالتالي فهنا ينظرون الى ما حدث يقولون
ما الذي يمنعه ان تحدث مغامره اخرى خاصه
وان الرئيس الكوري الشمالي لا ينظر اليه
بعين الثقه ينظر اليه بكثير من الريبه
لذلك هذا التعاون الامريكي الكوري الجنوبي
هو بالنسبه لكوريا يخدم مصلحه الطرفين
بحكم ان التهديد القادم من كوريا الشماليه
يتوجه للطرفين
من الصول مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي شكرا
جزيلا لك